Listen, we all love Disney and Pixar, they've probably made more classic films than any other studio.
We grew up loving the work the did, like virtually everyone alive.
But that doesn't mean they get everything perfect. Every once in a while they make a film with a plot hole
so big, it could ruin your enjoyment of the movie, if the movie wasn't so darn good otherwise.
Nevertheless, we're going to point out a few of the mistakes to see if you recognise them.
Here are ten Disney plot holes that everyone ignores.
Remember, if you want to see more lists like this, subscribe to our channel and make sure to join our notification squad.
And before we start, can you guess this movie from these emojis? Stay tuned for the answer at the end of our video.
scary feet scary feet scary feet oh the kid's awake
Monsters University
Monsters University takes the characters we know and love from Monsters Inc. and reveals how they first met
At the Oozma Kappa fraternity of Monsters University, at least thats what this prequel would have you believe
the original film Mike Wazowski tells
Sully you've been jealous of my good
luck since the fourth grade panel
apparently Pixar tried to workshop a
version of the script in which these two
characters met in fourth grade and then
reconnected in college but it just
didn't work so you're just gonna have to
put up with the inconsistency sorry
hey ham! look i'm Picasso! eh I don't get it
Toy Story
part of the plot of toy story is that
all of the toys know that they're toys
which is why they all freeze in their
place when humans come around them.
This rule is complicated when Buzz Lightyear
arrives fresh from the toy store and
doesn't seem to realize that he's not
actually a Space Ranger as his packaging
would suggest and yet when Andy or his
mother enters the room was still freezes
in place what do you think should Buzz still
be flying around in the presence of
humans? How do toys actually learn that
they're toys in the first place?
The Little Mermaid
In the little mermaid Ariel
makes a deal with the evil sea witch
Ursula to go gain human legs and try to
win the kiss of her true love Prince Eric
the catch is that she must trade her
beautiful voice for her new set of legs
so when she arrives on land she's unable
to tell Eric who she is but we already
saw Ariel read and sign the contract
laid out for her by Ursula
she lost the use of her voice not
her hand so why can't she just write
down her feelings for Eric?
We will be sending a real dragon to retrieve Mulan
What... What?! I'm a real dragon!
Mulan
At the beginning of this Disney classic Mulan
disguises herself as a man and joins
the army to save her elderly father from
being drafted but it doesn't seem all
that simple Mulan is almost sent home
after failing to meet the physical
requirements of her captain Lee Shang
but she persevered and gets to go to war
with the boys. The only problem is if the
young Mulan almost failed to meet the
physical requirements of these soldiers
than her feeble elderly father almost
certainly wouldn't have made it so why did
she even bother to sign up ?
Genie of the lamp
Aladdin
In Aladdin the villain
Jafar wants to get a hold of the genie
in order to become the Sultan himself he
claims that the genie's magic is much
more powerful than his and that's why it
would be necessary to wish his way to
the top. But Jafar's magic already
seems pretty powerful to us he even uses
his weird serpent-y staff to transform Aladdin
Back into a peasant after the
genie turns into a prince it seems to us
like it wouldn't have taken much more
magic than that to work his way to the
top would the genie really have made
things that much better for him?
So this is love
Cinderella
We all know how Cinderella
ends after midnight Cinderella and her
magic pumpkin carriage are transformed
back to their original states after she
flees from the ball in terror of being
found out for who she really is but the
prince upon finding a lost glass slipper
at the ball searches the land for the
woman whose foot will fit inside but why
didn't the slipper also disappear at
midnight what do you think is there a
better explanation for how this
fairytale ends? sorry boys I don't tangle
Sorry boys I don't sing
Tangled
for most of Tangled our long haired
heroine Rapunzel is as blond as can be Though the hair turns brown whenever it's
cut off from her head presumably this
has something to do with the hairs
magical healing properties however at
the end of the film Eugene slices off
all of her hair in order to prevent her
from being kidnapped by the evil Gothel
this time all of her hair turns brown
including the hair that's still attached
to her head how did this happen she got
a haircut not a dye job
What is dinner without a little music?
Music?
Beauty and the Beast
According to the lore of Beauty
and the Beast the prince was cursed at
the age of 11 when he was still a boy
yet when Belle is exploring the house
she discovers a portrait of the Prince
as a handsome human man torn to shreds
by the bitter peace but how did this
portrait get made if he was transformed
into a beast at the age of 11 it is
possible that it's a Dorian Gray type
painting showing the Beast how he would
look if you weren't trapped in the body
of the beast but that should have been
explained that there were the case.
Please just stay away from me stay away
Frozen
When Elsa's powers are revealed
in Frozen the whole town is horrified
thinking that their queen is some kind
of monster this causes Elsa to flee to
her ice castle in the mountains where
Anna must come to find it but after the
sisters defeat the evil Hans the town
cheers for her. Why? She's done nothing to
change their minds about her powers they
didn't even know that Hans was plotting
against Anna and Elsa
from the beginning what do you think did
the town's folk have ample reason to
rally around their queen in the end?
The Incredibles
the villain in
The Incredibles, Syndrome, has video cameras
installed all over his island. He also
has a bunch of henchmen who have been
fighting with the Incredibles and so they
should have been familiar with their
powers they should have known for
example that Violet would have been able
to use her force field to interfere with
the electronic devices used to hold down
the Incredibles while they were imprisoned
on his island and yeah well that's
exactly what she does
That's all for
this list but be sure to subscribe to
the Screen Rant channel and sign up for
the notification squad.
Thanks for watching